nicole you said that filming the grape
scene was was your favorite what was so
fun about filming that moment was it
like gosh i'm doing this iconic thing
here i mean it was all
all
fantastic when i look back at it the
grape scene was very freeing it was like
i get to do this and there's no dialogue
in that and to really
um be able to
revere her in a way i i was like what
she accomplished
with nothing um and the idea of just
stomping some grapes and it is
so so funny still it holds up timeless
um and then to have the chance to work
on that yeah it was a it was very
freeing for me as a as a person
[Music]
[Music]
you're my hero i need to know after
seeing it one of my favorite scenes you
play in the bongos singing babalu after
all of that how how good can you say of
a singer and and musician have you
become
me myself yes
i don't know
well you didn't do any of that before
right and i mean my guy
what i did in the little mermaid that is
still to come out and i
and after this i've done another musical
called lilac crocodiles i don't know my
career has changed
he's on a roll yeah yeah i'm touring
prison
i can dig it nicole you can be his hype
woman on stage like you do for keith and
just get up there and dance i'll dance
in the background yeah
happy to do it what was it like getting
to do babalu getting to sing that song
well actually babalu was not included in
the first draft really the script and uh
because aaron thought it was a little
bit too challenging and i said we have
to
make it and also i play drums so the
conga thing i wasn't worried about i
played
and i was taught
by
alfredo reyes jr which is the most
amazing drummer conga player one of the
most amazing and best in the world
has played with carlos santana
chicago
so
i got that covered it was the same in
part that it took me a little bit of
an effort
well whatever you did to your singing
coach whomever bravo great great cop
bruce ball is a threat to the american
way of life
does the fbi have any case against lucy
i need you to help me save my marriage
how many times i gotta explain where i
was and what i was doing you gotta
explain are you being funny i'm lucille
ball when i'm being funny you'll know i
love lucy really was a breakthrough when
she was in her 40s and she was the first
woman to be pregnant on television and
all of this stuff to have this success
at that age do you think about that and
do you think i mean
you know she really did set the table
for so many of us she did i mean they
both did in the sense of they
they
desi lou was a production company actors
didn't do that at that time they didn't
have their own production company
together
and they didn't just do the lucy show
they did star trek mission impulse i
mean they had a slew of projects that
went on to be massively successful so
they were both great business people as
well as creative people which i find
fascinating in which the film delves
into and you really see that and then
you see all of the pressures of just
being
a marriage and working and working
together and
at that time and then all of the um
things that happened that have been
compressed into a week
which is the one um dramatic license
aaron salkin took was pressing all these
things into a week but they all happened
they're riveting
they really are
you speak about them being you know kind
of a power couple and it leaves me i
mean
you all know a little something about
being a celebrity
power couples so in in making this movie
and and seeing kind of how they had to
balance sharing the spotlight or working
around each other or even planning work
around each other and their families do
you relate to or even i mean sympathize
in some of the moments that we see in in
this film from them yeah and i just love
that they um were a team i mean he
was desi was so protective of lucille
when i first read the screenplay
i i read it as a love story i mean yes
it's actors putting on a show and
all of the machinations that go into
that but primarily it's a love story
it's a tragic love story but it's a love
story
and that's what i think is um surprising
to people
because you really get a sense of their
of what they accomplish together but how
much love they have for each other and
javier how about you do you relate to
that you know being part of a you know
celebrity couple
a great love story
yeah of course um the terms of
popularity of these two people were i'm
being
so huge that i cannot even think of
what would that mean at the time i mean
they were seen by millions of people
every week and also
they were exposing themselves on their
privacy on a show yeah where there were
playing a marriage
a happy marriage
while maybe on the behind the scene part
it wasn't
that
um happy maybe i don't know
so i don't know that that must be very
very hard to
maneuver i think about too like what if
they had to deal with what you all have
to deal with us asking 50 million
questions every day paparazzi around all
the time well they had the paparazzi i
mean that's in the film there's the
tabloids and
that's very much penetrates their
relationship i mean it's how the how the
story opens so yeah
but they did and they had the public
consensus and
um i think they i mean i don't know her
but
i think desi one you know i had the
sense that he liked the spotlight
way more than i would
say i like myself yeah and nothing wrong
with that but uh
it wasn't his
energy that one
he wanted to be in spotlight i get paid
a fortune to do exactly what i love
doing uh they got their money's worth
pictures i work side by side with my
husband who is genuinely impressed by me
and all i have to do to keep it is kill
for 36 weeks in a row okay let's go i
just remember you know in the last few
years we've really been talking about
you and rhys and the things that you
guys have done and doing you know really
creating a legacy of your own so um in
what ways do you hope that your legacy
of work akin to like some of the things
that lucille ball has done has broken
some barriers in this industry for a
woman i mean i just hope that it's it
allows other um
people to have to go oh we can do that i
mean the idea of producing your own
shows i didn't produce this i'm
an actor that got you know
offered a role which was like thank you
so i'm still very much in that lane as
well but occasionally i step into being
a producer and and navigating all of
that as well and it's it's it's
wonderful i mean even when you see the
way they collaborate and
and they make so many of the decisions
um but they're still up against an
enormous amount and they're still being
told what to do
from the higher powers and so
um and then having to go no we want to
do it this way and we want to do it this
way and you'll see it's going to work so
trying to always
broaden and expand a viewpoint they had
60 million viewers every single time
that show was on
which is kind of hard to fathom
like
as aaron says in the screenplay at the
beginning
the water wasn't used at that particular
time in america because everybody was
what they could see the water levels
people weren't turning on their taps or
going to the bathroom or taking a bath
or a shower when the show was on
that's how powerful that show was wow
yeah
yeah
but that's great writing because that
explains to you
the way in which you penetrated the
culture i mean there's nothing that does
that now
[Music]
you